Here are two other expressions with absolute value. I'm going to apply the
order of operations and then the absolute value to get my answer. Absolute
value acts as a grouping symbol. I need to evaluate any expressions inside of
it first. But it's a particular grouping symbol, because it means the distance
from zero. So whenever I get my answer, I need to figure out, how far is that
answer from zero? Have the absolute value of the negative of 3 squared plus 2
times 4 squared. Remember, whenever there's a negative sign standing alone.
It's really a negative 1 times. So I'm going to have my absolute value. I'll
have 3 squared, which is 9. The negative one right before it. Then plus 2 times
4 squared. When I look at what to do next, I know I still have a power. I'm
going to do 4 squared. 4 times 4 is 16. Now I'm going to do the multiplication.
Negative 1 times 9 is negative 9. And 2 times 16 is 32. I'm going to add 32 and
negative nine, or 32 minus nine. And I get the absolute value of 23. The
absolute value or the distance of 23 from zero is 23. Okay for the second
problem I have the negative of the absolute value of negative 9 minus 3, times
the quantity 5 minus 2 squared. Remember, here's a negative side standing
alone. So I really have negative 1 times this value. So negative 1's on the
outside, and then absolute value symbol. When thinking about what to do next, I
need to start with this inside parentheses. I'm going to go ahead and list
negative 9 minus 3. For this inside parentheses, I'll do 5 minus 2 squared. I
know 2 squared is 4. So I have 5 minus 4. My negative 1 is still on the
outside. I have absolute value of negative 9 minus 3 times 1. Now I'm going to
do multiplication. I have the absent value of negative 3 minus 3,. Minus 9 and
minus 3 is negative 12. So, I have minus 1 on my outside and minus 12 inside my
absolute value. When I take the absolute value of negative 12, I get positive
12. The distance, or the absolute value of negative 12 from 0 is 12. So I have
negative 1 times a 12. Notice that when I take the absolute value of something,
I no longer need to write the symbol absolute value. I've taken its positive
distance from 0. The distance of negative 12 from 0 is 12. Then, my final
answer, I have negative 1 times 12, or negative 12.